- Really toxic people, I avoid.
I treat film like the military.
I got out to Hollywood and discovered
an incredible lack of money.
You are all going to die.
- Hello, Believe Nation!
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems.
So to help on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from director Joss Whedon
and my take on his top
ten rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening,
if something really resonates with you,
there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down the comments below
and put it in quotes so that
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
- Do you like actors?
(audience laughing)
Generally speaking?
(laughing)
I'll just, I'll be back
in a couple of minutes.
- The weird thing is--
- La la la la la la.
- As many of my best friends
are actors as writers.
I love actors, and I did not think...
I had served...
Again, in the old school, it's
an adversarial relationship.
And I've worked with my share of divas.
But, I also have enormous
respect for divas.
They're usually people who
do something extraordinary,
and know it, and show up and do it.
And you have to deal with
a lot of other stuff.
But they usually come in and say,
you're going to have to deal
with a lot of other stuff.
I'm a diva.
So here we go.
(audience laughing)
And then you get this beautiful work,
and you're like, okay,
thanks for the heads up.
Really toxic people, I avoid.
I cast for sanity.
That's a very important thing to me.
But toxic people are different than divas.
Divas are complicated,
but they know that there is a simplicity
to what they're going to give
you that you need and want.
Truly toxic people are just about
trying to tear something down.
Whether it's somebody else in the thing.
Whether it's the story.
They're about power.
Those people have no business in my life,
and, as far as I'm
concerned, in the industry.
As a filmmaker, you have to...
It's sort of the bad teacher thing.
You have to be sure.
When you're working for somebody else,
that's it, they're the boss.
I treat film like the military.
I always have.
Film and television.
When I'm working for someone,
and they're telling...
If they're Henry Fonda in Fort Apache
and they're making all
the wrong decisions,
I listen to them.
Because someday, I'm going to take over,
and I'm going to expect the same thing.
And it's not that I don't want dissent
or I don't want a creative collaboration,
that's very exciting for me.
But you have to be in
charge, know what you want,
and know that you have
the ability to get that.
And requires a lot of
fierceness and a lot of belief.
More belief than other people
are going to have in you.
When I shot...
The first thing I ever shot
was a pilot presentation
for Buffy, and it was a nightmare.
None of the crew understood
what I was trying to do,
or thought I could do it.
And there was a point when
I just wanted to fold.
I was just...
Can I please go home now?
And be a writer.
But I was miserable just being a writer
because I wasn't creating the thing whole
that I wanted to.
And at some point in the shoot,
I just said to myself,
this is it, this is your pep talk.
You're either going to go home
and regret it for the rest of your life,
or you're going to go in
there and run this thing.
And I never looked back.
- Your first work, it
was a television job.
I think it's Roseanne, is that correct?
- [Joss] Yeah, that was my first job.
- So was that,
did you always want to do television?
I know you come from a television family.
Or did you go out to
Hollywood to work in film
or television?
How did that work?
- I would never do television.
That was beneath me.
(audience laughing)
I studied film.
- And my best friend senior
year used to taunt me.
He's like, you're going
to be a third generation
television writer.
I am not! Quit it.
3G TV.
(audience laughing)
He called me that all the time.
And then I, I got out to Hollywood
and discovered an
incredible lack of money.
(audience laughing)
- So I sort of started
poking my nose around,
and realized, oh, there's
some very good television
that's being made.
And as soon as I started writing it,
it was really the first
writing I'd ever done.
Other than my television specs
that I wrote trying to get a job.
That's when I fell in love with writing,
was through television.
And I had the privilege
to work on Roseanne,
which was the best show on.
Really, it had a level of
reality that no other show
was really busting out just then.
- Was it difficult to push
storyline like Willow and Tara's
lesbian love on TV at the time?
- No, we did it very gradually.
I'm not sure they knew
that that's what it was.
(audience laughing)
For sometime.
Boy, that seems like a very
intense spell they're casting.
I'm like, yes!
(audience laughing)
Sorry, my voice is so
loud in my ear that I...
Again, I've always sort of
approached things with the idea
that whoever is giving me
all that money to put it on
is my partner.
And that I'm not working against them.
I'm trying to work with them.
I'm trying to find the space between
my artistic expression,
their commercial needs.
And my artistic expression is commercial.
I want to make things that people like.
I'm not wearing a beret and
sitting in a garret smoking.
(audience laughing)
'Cause it makes my stomach hurt.
But, I understand
what they need and what they want.
And I like that.
And I also think with audiences...
I used to say, we could of made Buffy
the lesbian separatist,
but let's start with vampire slayer
and let's see where it turns.
(audience laughing)
You always want to sort of get people
at the edge of their comfort level.
There are a lot of things that I do
that people are like,
whoa, that's pretty edgy.
I'm like, really?
I don't...
It surprises me that
it's not more mainstream.
Let's just say
hypothetically that two roads
diverged in a wood.
And you took the path less traveled.
Part of you is just
going, look at that path!
Over there is much better.
Everybody's traveling
on it, and it's paved.
There's like a Starbucks every 50 yards.
This is wrong.
On this one, there's nettles
and Robert Frost's body and...
Somebody should have moved that, I think.
This feels weird.
And not only is your
mind telling you this,
it is on that other path,
it is behaving as though
it is on that path.
It is doing the opposite
of what you are doing.
And for your entire life,
you will be doing, on some level,
the opposite, not only
of what you are doing,
but of what you think are.
That is just going to go on.
What you do with all your heart,
you will do the opposite of.
And what you need to do
is to honor that.
To understand it.
To unearth it.
To listen to this other voice.
All right, I'm losing this now.
Otherwise it's coming
off in a dramatic fashion
at the wrong time.
I know, I worked on this
hair for a long time, so.
I had to bust it out.
You have, which is a rare thing,
the ability and the responsibility
to listen to the dissent in yourself.
To at least give it the floor.
Okay, because
it is the key, not only to consciousness,
but to real growth.
To accept duality is to earn identity.
And identity is something that
you are constantly earning.
It is not just who you are.
It is a process that
you must be active in.
And it's not parroting your parents
or even the thoughts of
your learned teachers.
It is now, more than ever,
about understanding yourself
so you can become yourself.
And I talk about this
contradiction and this tension,
there's two thing I want to say about it.
One, it never goes away.
And if you think that achieving something,
if you think that solving something,
if you think a career or a relationship
will quiet that voice,
it will not.
If you think that happiness
means total peace,
you will never be happy.
Peace comes from the
acceptance of the part of you
that can never be at peace,
that will always be in conflict.
If you accept that,
everything gets a lot better.
The other reason is
because you are
establishing your identities
and your beliefs,
you need to argue yourself down
because somebody else will.
Somebody's going to come at you,
and whatever your belief,
your idea, your ambition,
somebody's going to question it.
And unless you have first,
you won't be able to answer back.
You won't be able to hold your ground.
You don't believe me, try
taking a stand on just one leg.
You need to see both sides.
Because I never studied writing,
I just sort of had to learn on the job.
My entire family, my mother, my father,
everyone around them,
teachers and writers.
Very erudite, very articulate people.
It was kind of hard for me
to sort of find a voice.
But it took me just training on the job,
working relentlessly
since the day I started,
to sort of discover
what it was that I was doing
and sort of discover the
structure behind the voices
that I was creating.
- How did you settle on Much Ado?
Is it your favorite Shakespeare
play, or is it just...
- It's up there.
It's not my very favorite.
But it is, it's one we
always talked about doing
because we knew Amy and
Alexis should definitely
be Beatrice and Benedick.
And it's all in one place.
It's sort of low stress.
But for years, I just didn't
have a take on the material.
And then, finally, when I realized I did,
I said, okay, it's go time.
And that really,
that movie exists because
of years and years
of working with actors
that I absolutely knew
could do that as though
it were live theater.
Could walk on set and never get it wrong.
Because the schedule was
exactly the same as a TV show.
No, actually it was worse.
It was actually tighter than
a regular network TV show.
Obviously the language slightly different.
And no stage directions practically.
So it was like a (expletive)
ton of work everyday.
You can only do that when you know
you have an ensemble who is that is just
strength to strength.
So it's really them.
They're my secret.
I mean, mine, my secret.
The pressure isn't greater
if you have characters
that already exist or, in
the case of the Avengers,
some of them had been cast
and had their own films.
Some of them were beloved from comics
but we were reinventing
them for the films.
Meeting everybody's
expectations really just means
meeting your own.
It means that you understand these voices,
and that the people that
you're making the film for
hear them the same way you do.
The people at Marvel are very clear
that when you make a film of a comic book
or when you make a film with
a character from another film,
you cannot do exactly
what was done before.
You have to translate it
to your own film.
You do it in their style,
in their sort of house style of Marvel,
which I grew up with.
And I feel I understand pretty well.
But you have to make it personal.
You have to translate
it to a new audience,
to somebody who hasn't seen or read
or any of the other things,
while keeping the essence of the thing.
Somebody will always argue.
That's the way you do it.
But nobody can argue with
my passion for doing it.
And I think that's what the
people are really looking for,
more than the specifics of
well, in the comics, his
costumes has epaulets up here.
Why didn't you blah blah blah?
- You had a really wonderful two years.
You've had a --
- It's over, is what you're saying.
- No, no, no, no!
- You had a good run,
thank you for coming.
- How do you feel about
where you are right now?
Are you--
- That it's over.
- Yeah, that's how we always feel, right?
- Yeah.
This is a bad one.
I mean, I know that you get
that after any project probably.
- It's over.
The jig is up.
They're going to know.
(audience laughing)
- Yep.
It's worse this time.
Partially because of the Ultron thing,
which was difficult.
And I...
I should just say, because I feel like,
I feel like part of...
Ultron, I am very proud of.
There were things that did
not meet my expectations
of myself.
Then I was so beaten down by the process.
Some of that was conflict with Marvel,
which is inevitable.
But a lot of it was about my own work.
And then, and I was also exhausted.
And then we went right
away and did publicity.
I sort of created the narrative wherein
I have not quite accomplished it.
And people just ran with that.
So it became, well, it's okay.
It could be better, but
it's not Joss' fault.
And I think that did a
disservice to the movie
and to the studio and to myself.
Ultimately, it was not the right way to be
because I am very proud of it.
The things about it that are
wrong frustrate me enormously.
And I had probably more of those than
the other movies I've made.
But, I also got to make,
for the second time,
an absurdly personal movie
where I got to talk about
how I felt about humanity
and what it means
in very esoteric and bizarre ways.
For hundreds of millions of dollars.
The fact that Marvel gave
me that opportunity twice
is so bonkers and so beautiful.
And the fact that I come
off of it feeling like
a miserable failure is also bonkers,
but not in a cute way.
It becomes problematic.
And i don't know what it's like for you.
I took my first vacation,
ever, after that movie.
And I don't mean ever,
but my first vacation
that was more than two weeks in 25 years
except for one 4 month vacation
where I wrote the Buffy musical.
(audience cheering)
That was lonely.
And so, I really set out to do nothing,
to accomplish nothing.
And I'm proud to say
that I have truly accomplished nothing.
- Did you get there?
- Yeah, I really,
I got to a higher state
of (expletive) it all.
- For you, that's a major departure.
- I'm proud.
And I'm also...
But my resting state is not a good one.
- You work hard.
- I work hard.
I love to work.
I love the work that I do.
And I'm very happy and grateful about it.
When I'm not doing it, I
remember that I hate myself.
So it's not good so much to be...
So the vacation's over.
Now I'm writing again, and so things--
- Are you back at it?
- Do you feel--
- Oh yeah.
When I was sitting where
you guys are sitting,
the speaker was Bill Cosby.
Funny man Bill Cosby.
He was very funny, and he was very brief,
and I think him for that.
But, he gave us a message
that I really took with me,
that a lot of us never forgot.
About changing the world.
He said, you're not going
to change the world,
so don't try.
That was it.
He didn't buy that back at all.
And then he complained about
buying his daughter a car,
and we left.
And I remember thinking,
I think I could do better.
I think maybe I could be a
little more inspiring than that.
And so, what I'd like
to say to all of you
is that you are all going to die.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so, this is a
good commencement speech
'cause I'm figuring it's
got to go up from here.
It can only get better, so this is good.
I mean, it can't get more depressing.
You have, in fact, already begun to die.
'Kay.
You look great.
Don't get me wrong.
And you are youth and beauty.
You are at your physical peak.
Your bodies have just
gotten off the ski slope
on the peak of growth and potential.
And now comes the black
diamond mogul run to the grave.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
TellingItLikeItIs2000 asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next top 10, check out the link
in the description, and
go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know
what was your favorite
message from this video?
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout to Oskar Andermo.
Oskar, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
doing a review on your YouTube channel,
and posting it on your
Twitter account as well.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support, man.
And I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- Today's book report is the
One Word by Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- [Audience member] If
there's a story you like,
it doesn't have to be Shakespeare,
that you haven't written,
it's a universe you haven't created,
what about it has to be
artistically fulfilling
or challenging for you to pursue it?
Because for me, what was surprising
about you doing Shakespeare
wasn't that it's not sci-fi or fantasy,
it's that you, for the
first time in a long time,
worked on a project you hadn't written,
and it wasn't a universe
that you had created.
- Yeah, really the only things I directed
that I hadn't written at all
were episodes of the Office and Glee
because I loved those shows,
and I knew the people who were doing them.
I was going to say I had free time,
but I'm pretty sure, I mean,
my career was on the skids.
Something like the
Avengers, it's been cast,
there's a whole huge history that I know.
It's all...
If you can't find your own way in,
then you just don't do it.
The fact of the matter is,
because I've been a script doctor,
before I was a showrunner,
I was used to coming in where
things were already set.
After the pilot of a show,
a lot of the work's been done.
And you're interpreting
what you've got there.
When you come in as a script doctor,
they're like, and then
he goes into a plane.
I'm like, I have a way better idea
that we already bought the plane.
It's good. I know.
It's good. I make it work.
I'm going to work with the plane.
It's a good, it's a good idea.
So, you sort of
you have to find the heart of the thing.
You find your heart of the thing.
With Marvel, I said,
look, I know what you want.
This is what I want.
I want to make a war movie.
I want to make the Dirty Dozen.
I want to make Blackhawk Down.
I don't want to make any
squeaky clean, perfect.
I want to take a toll on these guys.
And they're like, we get that, we love it.
Do it in the mighty Marvel manner,
and everybody wins.
So, we knew going in that
I had my obsessions and that
they fit in that universe
With this, it's a question
of interpreting his work
the way I would, which is
in a depressing fashion.
(audience laughing)
It's very easy to fall
in love with something.
What? The entire world
is covered with water?
Include me in.
(audience laughing)
And yes, you can get heartbroken,
but you have to start that way.
The parameters, they always exist.
If you're doing a genre,
if you're doing...
It's a comedy. They must laugh.
Already the page is not totally blank.
So, how much of it is filled in?
Whether it's completely written like this.
Whether it's, where there
are a lot of elements
that are set, like the Avengers.
Or whether it's a show that's yours,
but it's been on for three years.
You always have to find the new way in.
- How do you go from
super-big budget Avengers to this?
Compressed, 12 day shoot in your home.
- Honestly, there's no difference
between the big movies and
the little ones for me.
You're always fighting
everybody's schedule.
In this case, because
they all had day jobs.
In the other case, because
they were all famous.
You're always getting your
set at the last minute.
You're always behind.
You're always worried
about the same things.
You're always trying to
communicate the same things.
Shooting is shooting.
Storytelling is storytelling.
If you're not writing about yourself,
why are you writing?
For me, if you're not telling a story...
Spinning a yarn is fine,
and there are some people
who are great at it.
And they're great at things
that I'm not great at.
Like intricate heist plots and things.
That I admire and envy, but...
If you're sitting down to write something
or make something that's
going to take three years
out of your life,
why would you not want to tell people
something that's important to you to say?
I don't mean a moral.
I just mean an examination
of the human condition.
You want, you want to
be able to talk about
the politics of personality.
And that's something it
took me a while to find.
I started to find it
on Alien Resurrection,
which is the last thing
I wrote before Buffy,
before the show.
That was the first time I went,
oh, this is a metaphor.
And the only way this works is
if I feel the way she feels.
And that was sort of the beginning
of becoming a storyteller,
instead of a yarn spinner.
And to me, if I can't do that,
if I can't make that connection,
then I'm wasting people's time.
And as much as I may look
back at anything I've made
and go, flawed, flawed,
flawed, flawed, flawed,
embarrassing, embarrassing,
I never feel like I did that.
I never feel like, well,
I wasted some of his time.
That's the biggest brag
I'm going to give you.